Robin Couderc alias robe a composé la
musique originale d'acide un film
catastrophe de juste Philippot présenté
au Festival de Cannes dont voici tout de
suite quelques images
c'est difficile de qualifier cette
musique parce qu'on essaye toujours
spécialement dans les films de genre
d'être original d'être expérimental
d'aller chercher des choses qu'on n'a
pas peut-être l'habitude d'entendre
ailleurs en tout cas on a essayé d'être
à la fois spectaculaire intimiste
à l'armiste peut-être c'est un film
profondément dur donc j'essaye d'être
toujours voilà du côté des personnages
de leur affection c'est à 10 ans que
Robin Couderc commence à expérimenter la
musique électronique il découvre le
cinéma 12 ans plus tard en composant le
premier court-métrage de sa femme pink
cowboys en fait j'ai assez vite compris
que ma musique se prêtait assez mal au
jeu on va dire commercial au jeu des
radios au jeu de la promo parce que
c'était une musique un petit peu hors
format hors cadre et que j'avais du mal
à la vendre et donc du mal à en vivre et
puis le cinéma est apparu dans ma vie un
peu comme une forme de Mécène c'est à
dire que tout d'un coup
cette qualité qui était un dans la pop
musique devenait une grande qualité pour
le cinéma c'est à dire une musique
singulière exigeante particulière
peut-être trop original pour la radio
mais suffisamment pour le cinéma la
musique du générique d'acide à quant à
elle était composé par Pierre Lefeuvre
alias CIC c'est une musique qui est
faite comme son indique pour sortir les
auditeurs du film en fait il y a une
vraie il y avait une volonté de juste le
réalisateur de d'aller sur une note un
peu d'espoir sur une autre couleur en
fait et après le ce que ce que a pu
poser robe sur sur ces images il voulait
aller sur sur une autre sonorité une
sonorité peut-être un petit peu plus
ouais qui portait sur un peu plus
d'espoir peut-être sur un peu plus de
lumière ah si d'un film de juste
Philippot avec les musiques de Robin
Couderc et Pierre Lefeuvre dont la
sortie en salle est programmée au 20
septembre